I have absolutely no idea what Iraq is
to be honest when I first heard the name
of it I thought of the country I'm told
that this is like a major iconic drink
in a lot of Middle Eastern countries
it's clear
I don't know that moonshine 50% alcohol
that's a really little bottle to contain
20 standard drinks so for Caitlyn
someone who doesn't drink often
this is gonna suck smells like black
licorice we go one-third Iraq and then
2/3 water like I don't get the whole
water thing like can you not just drink
it straight oh it's weird is that milk
you know dishwashing what I don't like
that it makes me feel like there's
something going on in there all right
Cheers
bottoms up oh it's Oh got you the first
initial taste is like really strong and
then it's great it kind of reminds me of
like an orzo or grappa I would say that
straight-up Galliano it's definitely and
I'm getting drunk drink you can
definitely taste the alcohol in this but
it's not overpowering which doesn't
really make sense cuz there's about 50
drinks in that that totally makes sense
now why we add add water this would be
dangerous doesn't even feel alcoholic it
feels like cordial that's meant to taste
like with a long never-ending shot of I
want to go home now please
I came in thinking I'll be drinking the
most ghastly drink ever but it was great
I don't think I'd be bringing this out
every weekend not at all
I'm feeling a buzz this is the prime
drink you can sneak into a music
festival yeah just say it's like fancy
water this is probably up there with one
of the strongest rings I've ever had
this right here is everything I want in
a drink it's easy to go down
it's alcoholic as hell and it's
refreshing great job guys love it so
they drink this in the Middle East yes
in countries like Iraq yep
I love this I rest right I love this